[Applaudissements]
allez talktalk tac tac tac tac je vous
entends pas tac tac tac on a branché son
micro voilà c'est juste une tranche à
monter ce que là je sais que c'est
benhaim elle ne fait pas que c'est que
de la télé c'est également tmp faut pas
lui enlever son micro que d'autres
techniques
la bnm qu'est ce que tu veux qu'elle a
jeté à terre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui qu'est ce que vous voulez la
secrétaire qui la secrétaire jean landes
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
une scène va faire une scène bonjour
bonjour aaa bonjour vous êtes la
secrétaire a tout à fait vous avez
rendez vous avec les médecins oui j'ai
rendez vous avec un certain docteur le
docteur qu'aux kasma notre secret c'est
que nos affaires oui parce que si c'est
un docteur aux méthodes peu orthodoxes
vous voyez ce que je veux dire à vous
êtes un monsieur hanouna
mais je suis à 100 avec un h comme un
animal
[Applaudissements]
très crédible très crédible je perdais
scène avec tout le monde sait comment où
on compte tu penses que je ferai un bon
acteur os x comme ça il peut pas avoir
un look
t'as le look mais t'as pas le voile a
dit allenou moi je vais te la mettre sur
la tête varité colisée tma-21 c'est
emmanuel est urgent et la mettre dans la
bouche tu veux dire match à dire papa de
noix de deux mois du pagne à trop dur où
on a fait sa rentrée en cm2 il ya que
des rôles ou comme ça un territoire
syrien
alors ton n'est pas pour villard de lans
kso
[Rires]